what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the tragic and
heartbreaking but extremely meaningful
legacy of her win Smith the commander of
the survey corps the mentor of levi and
the guy who can lose an arm to a titan
and still scream shinzou all Sassicaia
until giant tears of pure manliness are
flowing down your face
irwin was a one-of-a-kind figure in the
world of attack on titan no one else can
compare to Irwin in terms of leadership
skills and the ability to motivate his
soldiers to move forward even in the
face of certain death it is no wonder
that even though he was always more of a
side character I've had quite a few
people tell me that urban is one of
their favorites or even their absolute
favorite character in the entire series
but the most interesting thing about a
win is what a nuanced and complex
character he is he is not just a
one-dimensional heroic leader of man who
stands for truth and justice he is also
a man with big flaws with a traumatizing
childhood and with an obsessive urge to
find out the truth about the world no
matter the cost as noted by Armin and
others Irwin had a very rare ability he
was capable of remaining cold and
calculating in the most extreme
situations and he was willing to send
hundreds of soldiers to their death in
the name of the greater good in the
world of attack on Titan change is
impossible for those who are not willing
to make big sacrifices and in some ways
Irwin sacrificed his own humanity in the
name of saving the rest of humanity from
the Titans her win' sacrificed the lives
of many including young inexperienced
soldiers and he often remained cold and
ruthless throughout because he always
prioritized the bigger picture and the
greater good of humanity
Irwin was an impressive military
strategist and he came up with
innovative techniques such as the long
distance enemy scout information which
saved many lives however her win' also
came up with military strategies that
required the loss of many lives such as
the suicidal charge that he led against
the beast Titan during the
to shegaon china ark a charge that
resulted in scores of dead survey corps
members just so Levi could sneak up on
the Beast Titan and take him out
Irwin's cold and ruthless commitment to
the cause of humanity inspired some to
refer to him as the human demon someone
who gave up his human emotions and
sentiments in order to do what had to be
done in the name of ultimate victory
even though
Erwin did feel remorse for all the
soldiers that died under his command he
always prioritized the mission and he
was willing to do things to other
individuals that normal humans would
consider cruel and appalling if that
meant advancing the cause of humanity as
a whole nevertheless during the battle
of chigan China when both urban and
Armand were on the brink of death Levi
who was certainly a lot closer to her
one than to Armand ultimately chose to
save Arman's life by turning him into a
Titan while allowing Aaron to die and
rest in peace in order to understand
this decision and the ultimate legacy of
her win' Smith we have to delve deep
into Owens tragic past
Erwin was the son of a schoolteacher and
so it isn't surprising that he was
always an inquisitive child even at a
young age
Erwin understood that the official story
about the walls and humanity that the
ruling regime was promoting didn't quite
add up
Erwin realized that the history books
that were being taught to him and the
other children were clearly subjective
he often asked his father how the
history books could make definitive
assertions that could not be confirmed
logically for example if we know that
humans are unable to venture outside the
walls then how can the history books
claim that all humans outside the walls
had gone extinct since humans cannot
venture far outside the walls they
cannot confirm that there are no other
humans out there somewhere so the fact
that the history books didn't just say
something like it is believed that all
humans outside the walls had got extinct
but instead made definitive claims that
humans had in fact gone extinct made our
win' instantly suspicious he realized
that these unverifiable claims were
being presented as fact for some
specific political purpose since his
father was a teacher
Erwin shared his misgivings about the
history books with his father
Erwin wondered why humanity had no
recollection
of the world outside the walls even if
all records of the outside world were
somehow lost shouldn't some information
about it still have been preserved
through word of mouth
meaning that older generations could
still have told the truth about the
outside world to their children
grandchildren and so on
Irwin's father had a theory that the
King had somehow managed to alter the
memories of humanity once they had moved
behind the walls because this made it
easier for the King to control them and
keep them in line
the young Arwen was fascinated by this
idea and he couldn't understand why his
father and other teachers were not
talking about this in the classroom
after all the purpose of classrooms was
to teach the truth and yet the truth was
being deliberately glossed over and
hidden from the students since he was
still young and not fully aware of the
consequences of his actions Irwin began
discussing his views about the truth and
how it was being covered up by the
government with other children
unfortunately word about Urban's
questions and theories reached the wrong
people and one day
Irwin's father met a tragic and although
his death was officially labeled an
accident
Irwin's father was killed by the
military police brigades first interior
squad the first interior squad is
basically a secret police that functions
independently from the military police
brigade and ensures that the order that
the King has established behind the
walls is preserved at all costs
even if that means eliminating everyone
who gets too curious about the outside
world the interior squad was responsible
for the death of Arman's parents after
they attempted to fly beyond the walls
in a hot-air balloon they were
responsible for the death of Aaron's
father and they were also responsible
for who knows how many more brutal
deaths of dissenters and those who were
just a bit too curious the young Earl
when eventually put two and two together
and he stopped asking too many
uncomfortable questions in public he
realized that his failure to keep his
theories to himself led directly to the
death of his father and this sense of
guilt combined with his natural
curiosity led to Irwin becoming obsessed
with finding out the truth for himself
and proving that his father had been
right all along when he learned that the
truth was hidden inside Aaron's basement
Irwin's obsession escalated to the point
that he even admitted to Levi that he
considered
bandung the fight for shegaon china
altogether just so he could find out
what was really in the basement before
he died
Irwin was so committed to finding out
the truth after all these years that he
was considering abandoning the cause of
saving humanity just so he could have
his own peace of mind by finding out
whether his theories were true Irwin
continuously defied death and led the
scouts into battles against the Titans
against all odds but his obsession with
fulfilling the dream that he shared with
his father his dream of finding out the
truth began to cloud his judgment and he
even admitted as much to leave on Irwin
became too willing to sacrifice anything
even his own men in the pursuit of his
childhood dream despite his amazing
leadership abilities his obsession with
the basement eventually ate away at
Owens own humanity this is one of the
reasons why Levi ultimately decided to
save Armin instead of erlan the final
decision was difficult and complicated
everything from the fact that Aaron
didn't want to power to the fact that
Armin was a strategic genius played into
Levi's choice it is true that Levi was
closer and more loyal to Irwin and it is
also true that Armin could not hope to
replace her when in terms of Aaron's
leadership qualities and his abilities
to inspire men to continue fighting
against all odds but while her wound was
certainly highly intelligent and while
he made many wise military decisions his
dream of finding out the truth at all
cost clouded his judgment and many of
Irwin's plans like the charge against
the beast Titan ultimately resulted in a
lot of casualties one could argue that
these casualties were unavoidable under
the circumstances but the fact remains
that in his plan to defeat the colossal
Titan Armin was able to achieve the goal
without sacrificing anyone else Armin
was willing to sacrifice himself and he
did almost die before Levi's decided to
save him instead of Aaron but Armand's
plan didn't require the sacrifice of
anyone else and even without heavy
sacrifices the plan succeeded in Bertolt
was defeated
finally Levi made the decision that it
was time for Aaron to rest and that he
should not be forced to continue
suffering in this cruel world and so
Erwin smith the greatest leadership
figure in the entire attack on Titan
series died in the
aftermath of the Battle of chigan China
but what was Urban's legacy how big was
his impact on the wider story and do his
life and death have any meaning in the
long term I think that Aaron is one of
the best characters in the entire story
precisely because he is such a
contradictory and complex figure on the
one hand
Irwin is a brave and highly intelligent
leader whose innovative strategy saved
many lives
his ability to motivate his soldiers and
command their loyalty and respect is
truly impressive and Irwin has made a
massive contribution to the fight to
save humanity behind the walls on the
other hand
Irwin is a deeply flawed human being in
his role as leader her wound has had to
give up some of his own humanity and he
is driven by a childhood obsession which
at times clouds his judgment and places
the future of humanity in jeopardy but
do his flaws and his ruthless
calculating nature really make her win'
a human demon I don't think so in fact I
think that his flaws and his inner
conflict make her one more human in the
eyes of the reader and the viewer in any
war leaders are forced to make many
difficult decisions and they are then
forced to live with the consequences we
can all relate to
Irwin's inner struggle and we can also
relate to the fact that he fell victim
to an obsession the guilt he felt over
his father's untimely death led him to
dedicate his life to finding out the
truth and proving his father's theories
but like any obsession this ultimately
had a profound impact on Irwin --zz
personality and on his decision-making
as someone who was also curious and
inquisitive by nature I was frustrated
when Aaron died before he could finally
achieve his dream of learning the truth
but at the same time I understand Levi's
decision and I think that Owens death
cements his legacy his contribution to
the survey corps is undeniable and
despite his obsession with the truth in
the end Levi's made the judgment that
her win' didn't want the serum and that
he preferred to die alongside the men
who sacrificed their lives for his plan
even if that meant giving up on his
lifelong dream of seeing the basement
and learn
the truth Irwin's legacy is a tragic one
he died young after failing to achieve
his dream but without Urban Smith the
survey Corps never would have gotten as
far as they did without her win' the
soldiers would have given up on the
fight to save humanity and retreated in
fear a long time ago without her when
the old regime would still be ruling and
oppressing the people while suppressing
the truth and without a win the truth
about the basement may never have been
revealed even though he himself did not
live to see it Erwin was a key player in
the survey Corps finally learning the
truth about what was happening beyond
the walls and it is this information
that gave them a fighting chance against
a previously completely unknown enemy
Erwin Smith reminds us that even a
normal human being as flawed and
imperfect as they might be can still
achieve great things and motivate
thousands of people despite their own
inner doubts and conflicts and even if
that person falls along the way the
impression that they left on others will
stay with them and levi's hanji Armin
Mikasa Eren and all the others will
continue to follow along the path that
her one paved for them even after his
death
Irwin's legacy is tragic but it is also
inspirational her win' was a hero to
some a ruthless demon to others but in
the end he was a complex contradictory
and conflicted human being just like the
rest of us and that is the tragic and
heartbreaking beauty of urban Smith's
life and legacy let me know what you
guys think do you like her 1 as a
character and what do you think of his
legacy how much of an impact do you
think that ruins life and death have had
on the story and can you relate to him
despite his often larger-than-life
character let me know down in the
comments if you enjoyed the attack on
titan content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell a huge thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work I want to give a
special thank you to our pro hero to
your patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man
and nothing but a fan and another huge
thank you to our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah a Lola nod of Maddy Mac and
Michael called that on if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]